but I do a piece in the show where I  sing the song Forever that I did on Full  House and I play a really beautiful clip  of him I found this audio of him just  talking about you know being good to  people and being nice to people and he's  got and he says I've had a lot of love  in my life and a lot of laughter and I  wish that for you and so I play that and  they'll be singing song  I I love that  that you know so present about him I  have so many beautiful last little texts  and our last dinner together was so  special and he wrote this beautiful post  about me being his brother and one of  the big heart breaks for me when he died  was that it was a tsunami of love for  him but this outpouring of love for him  he and I don't think he knew how loved  he was and it was just it was beautiful  to see all these people saying all these  wonderful things about him but I just  felt so bad that he couldn't either hear